so you've had no problem with sexual  functional urination Wow when the first  erection happened post-surgery wheels  when did it let you dance  Oh celebrated dance  um this might be your next movie but Ted  came in to check me out and I just went  right on well it was literally like the  like the night after show doctor you  like come here you guys like yes they  showed it to him no and show it to my  Wow what are you doing yeah how soon did  you get your first erection seriously  after the it was like the night after  the surgery yeah the night after the  surgery Wow it was when you shocked by  that is that typical and that's not  typical but you know he's a family movie  stars each event over